three questions all involving a dread
some ways range of us for what we have
to do to distraction and pappad water to
get to the answer which I thought I just
provide for us what do we actually do
and please you know I've got a great
place to whether please don't say super
high what did we actually do we divided
what do we divide by two please
if you divide by two the first thing
you'll get is for a so in addition / -
you also / okay so you can just do both
of those in one here of course if you do
the talk then you also do the bottom why
did we choose to a because it in color
with both which is why you send up to
the top and bottom so fantastic what's
good how do you only this one here right
in single fraction you can see you're
ready to write up some wording here what
is important about that line what does
it accomplish that we didn't have it
before why don't you hand your hair not
say it yes really
okay so these like a peanut curry rolls
and they're the nuns are country called
coffee they've changed but why did we
change them like it is useful but why
French okay great if he turns down the
bottle that I mopped up now they're
talking the same language so these
different turning on the top I can
combine them okay do you notice a tango
15 is negative seven eight so make sure
you include them all right last one
there here
Leo's got quite a few like they're
working so let's step through it what's
the first slide achieved
what's better than right okay so we've
stared leibrandt's are they gone what's
the usefulness to expanding often I ask
you to factorize why is it useful to
expand in this case because you can
but don't you TiVo it
what do you think yeah you can collect
light turns right sweetie is a piggy
three into plus five should say minus
three she's added three at both sides
and then he had twelve to young added 3m
PE subscribe today for both signs 12 a -
a looks good 5 plus 20 looks good my
lady / little cubby wonderful so these
review questions include algebraic
fractions include equations so surprised
from it we would get equations with
algebraic fractions now here's all we
going to do what a narrowly I'll run you
through these examples and they'll let
you have a go
however I want to tell you what these
notes are about so instead of running
through the examples of then letting you
have a go I'm gonna run through these
examples and then I'll just going to ask
you to do this solid we look it's really
short and then I've got to up this bill
is about and play video that goes with
it
so a bit of a different thing so let's
try and go through this really quickly
because I want to make sure we have time
for this these are equations equations
and they have algebraic fractions in
them so then you know how to deal with
these for the pedigree
we should be unmanaged do we need
together so let's have a look
I try to solve each of these equations
try to find a value on the proving rule
that makes the equation true because not
just true free value if I put in N
equals 1 or true or N equals 0 lot truth
is a particular n of a stop so what
shall I do what can I do to both sides
that would get me towards something to
block I multiply both sides by 3 so that
get through the branch were left inside
on the right you get
man you've been fantastic and this is a
pretty simple one star is so all I need
to do to get to the solution in subtract
five so I subtracted from here which
things you eat more chappy negatives
good common error to make it to write
negative 25 why would someone write
negative 25 because they're taking away
5 from that number forgetting the sign
there okay so watch out okay now have a
look at this one similar kind of idea
again the first kind of obstacle your
weight is the fraction so what should I
do to everything I multiply by two
I just watch out when I multiply this
guy by 2 I get fine outside one month
that's all fun ok but this guy key are
also gets multiplied by 2 so it becomes
minus 2
lastly the right-hand side that becomes
peeps so please watch out when terms of
separate out by addition or subtraction
you multiply all right so that's fine
just like here I have brackets I should
get rid of it why should I get rid of
them again big likely - it allows us to
collect like terms so let's do that I'm
going to have 5 minus 5n now look again
and then that minus two of the six are
just still pretty out there doing their
due ok now I'm ready to sort of get
everything all in one spot so you can
see gr fire take away 2 5 10 going to is
3 so there's a plus 3 on this side
posturing besides I might as well
subtract 3 from both sides which will
leave me with just 3 that ok what's left
over here is minus 5m so if I want to
get and on its own I'm going to yeah
tell me I know you've done if you type
wider division why is that the operation
in truth why do I take rinses which I
see mother times why not add 5 different
size cuz minus 1 why is it division
series of
500 okay very good there's an operation
implied here isn't it like we just don't
like to sponsor but multiplication is
really what's going on here which is why
differences or undo it
so I'll just divide both sides by
negative five oops
we can't about the beatings or something
the problem with this equation or the
first obstacle to overcome are the
fractions so what can I do to get rid of
all the fractions in one hit have it big
cover the whole country okay so if I
multiply by 4 and by 3 we can 12 that
will get rid of all the fractions in one
kid okay now watches can't play just put
your piss out of it and what it is if I
look like everything by 12 then the
first thing there's the second thing and
then there's the Thursday yeah so if I
start all three of them their district
rid of go to piece practice but watch
out under C is 4 right the Tom before
kids leaving behind three like that and
the 12 the three will cancel leaving or
four okay now here's the thing I'm so
anxious for YouTube searches okay
look back at the first one he added a
pair of fractions on there the left-hand
side okay people often see a pair of
fractions they like cool I know exactly
what to do I will cross multiply that's
the thing that you do with a pair of
fractions right and they're so very
close to being right because do you
notice that sort of that sort of looks
like what's happened do you notice that
it looks like cross multiplication with
one very very important difference have
a look at the right hand side and look
oh yes
yeah very good cross-multiplying means
multiply both of these by 12 which is
what ends up moving the denominators but
if you multiply the left-hand side by 12
you also could do the right-hand side
and it's the most common error and it
drives me crazy every time I fear for
students to cross multiply on the left
and then just leave the right-hand side
untouched okay but what you really need
is a native component what you really
did it smelled like everything my 12 so
that's why over here you're going to get
something just also be multiplied by 12
please don't miss that I'm put in a big
color that's different if you want to
learn highlight it and now we can solve
it just like we just performed their
brackets what I'm gonna do with them
let's expand so I'm going to get 18 pay
take away 3 watch out this negative is
going to apply to everything so that
means minus 4 a minus minus 8 very good
so that's another easy thing to mess up
so I follow the pot there we have a bus
there it's not because the negative
that's Matix so on this left-hand side I
see I have minus 11 minus 11 so
therefore I should probably add 11 to
both sides
how many eggs will I be left with you
42 oh yeah so therefore now I just have
to define can you simplify that any more
I don't think you can I think I didn't I
think it does you can double checking
separated right but I'm pretty sure that
it's good to get